Military experts are wondering what they're
up to after looking at satellite images is
-- this was taken in February and another
military nuchal there.
>> But in this image, from late March all
that equipment is gone.
It's unclear whether vehicles removed or why
but local pre Russian officials suggest and
expect that the Ukrainian counter offensive
could target that area.
>> Let's bring in CNN's beijing bureau chief.
Steven Jiang.
Also here in London.
Not a Beshear.
First of all Stephen this call between zelenskyy
and she is highly significant and says a lot
about XI's position on the world stage.
>> Yes maxim ball ugly very significant and
remember this has been rumored for a long
time.
Especially after XI game back from Moscow
after his visit with Putin last month.
And especially after that flurry of diplomatic
visits to
[4:35:44 AM]
flurry of diplomatic visits to beijing by
European leaders and you have macron and Von
Der leyen and on top of that you have this
growing desire butternut to be seen as a global
peacemaker following the deal they brokered
between the Saudis and Iranians.
So it's in this broader context that we finally
saw this highly anticipated called take place.
That's also why some adults see this call
as a reward from beijing to Europe's willingness
to engage with China on this issue.
But let's not forget what just happened in
the past few days.
The Chinese ambassador, to France, causing
a uproar, across Europe when he questioned
in live French television, the legality of
the sovereignty of former soviet states.
Even though beijing has since disown those
remarks that the damage has been done.
So the need for damage control may have already
tip the scales in favor of this rather modest
suggestion according to some, adolescent that's
why we finally saw this call on Wednesday.
Now, of course XI reiterated the long-standing
talking points.
[4:36:44 AM]
points.
But he did pledge, for the first, time to
send a special envoy to Ukraine.
And other regional countries to discuss, quote
unquote a political settlement.
But even state media here has acknowledged
nothing is likely to change.
And, the short term given between Russia and
the position
--
-- China skeptics and critics in Europe about
that how it's not serious to play an unbiased
role by no limits partnership with Russia.
, And one thing this call does indicate of
course is that China is not willing to engage
with Ukraine and it is definitely trying to
show Europe that it wants to play a more active
and constructive role in ending this war in
Europe they're increasingly a battlefield
in the strategic rivalry in China and the
united States.
Max, Bianca.
>> Okay, Steven thank you.
>> CNN's nada Bashir is here following the
latest developments for us in Ukraine.
Not, a lot of merciless he said that at the
beginning of the,
[4:37:47 AM]
that at the beginning of the, year 2023 would
mark the Ukraine's victory against Russia.
Is what we're seeing on the battlefield suggest
that possibility?
>> Well, look the war is suddenly still grinding
out and we have seen intensification of those
just overnight in fact.
We've seen the mykolaiv region come under
attack.
Biden, Russia armed forces have one person
confirmed to have been killed by the Ukrainian
authorities.
After the Russian armed forces launched four
missiles from the black sea.
We've heard from the Ukrainian authorities
that they believe that high position weapons
were used in that -- meeting that the civilians,
needing infrastructures, were targeted deliberately
as we have seen over the past few months of
this grinding.
More yet President-Elect ski has been to the
Ukrainian armed forces and he spoke that yesterday
addressing the same they're see it another
crime against humanity that they will be held
accountable.
But we've also seen further attacks in the
zaporizhzhia region.
More than 80 attacks.
Drone attacks.
Missile attacks.
Artillery attacks according to local military
officials there.
[4:38:47 AM]
local military officials there.
They are killing at least two people.
So this is still ongoing.
And it is grinding on.
We heard, yesterday from the U.S. Military
official assessing the situation on the ground
that this is the U.S. General for Europe.
Christopher, we boarded the mound forces are
actually larger at this point now than they
were at the beginning of the war.
This is despite the significant losses that
we know the Russian armed forces have sustained.
And he actually said the Russians armed forces
still have plenty of options on the table.
So, this will be a significant concern for
Ukraine.
And of course for nato and Ukraine's other
international allies.
But, that's, and Christopher also said that
the Ukrainians are in a good position when
it comes to the potential for a